today i want to talk about
data unit tests and what they are and
why we need them but before
let me ask you a similar question like
do you have problem with your data
can you
raise your hand please
yeah so you see
not feeling alone
um so yeah that's what i want to talk
about um so let's
let's go into the agenda and what we
have basically what i want to talk about
is
what's uh
begin with a short introduction then i
will define what our data unit tests and
explain
the importance when you build
any kind of data products and i will
also present some frameworks to perform
data unit tests and also show some live
code
and finally i will tell you a bit more
what's how we are uh tackling that at
get your guide my company
and
uh yeah i will conclude and open for
questions i'm really looking forward for
any comments that you have or things
that you think
you are doing
and are working great
so yeah uh
let's introduce so i
uh says i'm theo i'm working at get your
guide
so in my company we basically build a
marketplace for travel experiences and
in my team we're responsible for the
recommendation and the ranking of
experiences in the platform that means
that we heavily rely on data to achieve
our goals so that's what we call
we basically we are building data
products
and this is why i want to talk about
data unit tests
so basically
data products combine code with data and
in classical software it's actually
quite common practice to ensure the
quality of the uh
to ensure the quality of your code with
automated tests
but here you the the focus is really on
testing your code uh to ensure your
quality of your data products you need
to validate your code
also because you're using it but also
your data
and one way to validate them is actually
to have a data unit test
and but actually you want just one thing
to step back so if you work on an
organization that have multiple
engineering teams so
any reasonable i as soon as you uh have
a
kind of certain size in the company
the code basically you you probably uh
the code that is that is owned by your
team and probably they that's the one
that have the most full contacts when
you change it like when you change
something you know it and if there is
something wrong you are looking for it
in someone you know when you are
changing
however the data that you are using is
probably not produced and transformed
by your team but by other teams that
have probably not the full context of
how you are using this data
and
so
and also the other things is like you
have probably a lot of data sources that
you need to use in your data process
like you know as an example for us like
we have around 15 data sources that we
need to combine for our ranking or and
or recommendation algorithm and i don't
think we are really crazy in there i
think that people that can go
way more than that
um yeah
that's
what i want to say so
the data is basically um
the idea is to verify some expectations
that you have on uh your production data
so basically i think that we we need to
make a clear distinction between uh
testing your algorithm and so for
example if you want to test your code
and like your that your algorithm is
able to handle some null value that's a
unit test like a classical unit test
however if you want to
to test that your data set do not have
uh
no or like not too many nodes that's
basically where this is a data index you
want to check that your production data
that you will use or to train a model
that do not have some certain properties
and so what things like for example that
you would like to test in some data unit
test you would like to check that
the the mean the max of the average of
the column value is okay like if you are
computing some kind of conversion rate
or
uh click-through rate it probably should
be between zero and one if it's negative
or
more than one you probably have
something wrong in your
in your data set
so you might want to verify that do not
have
missing value or maybe not too many
missing values
you might you want to verify that do not
have duplicates
in some columns or that you have the
number of sample is reasonable so if
suddenly your number of samples will
jump from around 10 000 to 10 million
probably there is some joint condition
that have been
done wrong somewhere in the middle
and yeah so
with that uh we will now have
an idea of what's data unit test what we
are trying to do and let's i want to
give you a look at some of the main
framework to perform them so the first
one i want to talk about i think there
was a already some uh
tutorial yesterday in the morning about
a great expectation
and i think that's the so that's the
most active project i've seen um and
it's also uh support most of the formats
or sql pandas pi spark
and
it also render data documentation which
i
think is pretty great so it's like human
readable documentation of the
expectation that you have on your data
and yeah that's the the pretty
interesting uh
uh
i mean the
the first one i i think we we can talk
about then i think the other one that is
pretty interesting is pandera
so it's quite active also uh it's uh and
it has no company behind like not like
great expectation
um
and still they they manage to have uh
quite some stars and still pushing some
new features like for example now you
have these pandas
uh they had these pandas
that was the the core id but now they
also plugged uh in some way with price
pack so it's it's quite recent
uh but they then basically you can
validate your
uh your pi spark also with that
your pi spark data frame
and
uh yeah and it's may but maybe it's like
more focused on validating the the
schema and there is no validation then
you also have like a very big one the uh
from tensorflow data validation which is
part of the tensorflow extended
ecosystem
and actually i was pretty surprised
that's
not very active currently and do not
have that many uh
uh
stars for
i
i was expecting a bit more but uh it's
pretty pretty interesting um and i think
that's one of the first one
and
yeah the thing is it's
which is pretty so it's pretty tightly
integrity with the rest of the
tensorflow ecosystem so
if you if you don't want to go with the
every chord or thing like that then this
looks like
pretty much much more complicated to to
do your pipeline with this uh to test it
and finally i think the other one that's
uh soda which is basically
from what i've seen i didn't really try
uh really indeed that but it looks very
similar to ge but it's more recent so i
can have a look at it and there are
other
vendors also that are providing sas but
that's the one where you can basically
see the codes i think like it's they
have an open source open source
uh
libraries that you can try
and yeah so to conclude a great
expectation is the the most feature
complete
and
that's what i want to
to talk about now um
so let's let's dive into the the key
features sorry it might be a little
repetition if you went to the uh great
expectation
um
tutorial but they have this concept of
expectations which is some assertion
that you have about the data so
basically a data unit test in some sense
and the most common use cases uh is
implemented so if you want to check that
a certain colon is between zero and one
they already have that so you don't have
to re-implement this or like that you
don't have too many nulls like all these
kind of things they already did it for
you
and also of course if you have some very
specific use case then you can still add
your custom use case like specific logic
to it like if you have any kind of
weird like not
not weird but uh
very specific to your business logic
test that you want to do on your data
then you can also implement it
then they have this also the concept of
data profiling so basically you can use
some data set that you know is correct
to build a draft expectation so
it you will still need to work on it
afterward but at least the idea is that
you will not start from scratch you
already start from something that
is
based on the data that you know is good
uh then uh of course you have this data
validation so basically you can validate
a new data set
um with define a defined collection of
expectations or collections or a
collection of expectations that you have
and then you can do some specify some
alerting by emails likes if something is
wrong so if one of your tests fail
basically and finally pretty pretty nice
thing is this data documentation
which uh auto render a documentation of
your data of your data and you can think
of it as like a constantly updated data
quality reports
it's pretty that's a pretty pretty cool
feature of great expectations
but yeah let's dive into uh an example i
think like one
some codes worth of 1000 slides so
uh
i will go can you see it here
perfect
is the size okay
yeah perfect so
here what i want to do is
um
sorry i'm i'm losing myself in this
slide um
yes so you want to create some
show i want to i want to show you how to
create some data unit tests using great
expectation
and because i'm french
we'll talk about wine
in this
so actually there is a wine quality data
set which is composed of two subsets a
red wine data set that we will use
basically to create some uh test on it
and then we'll have the white wine that
i said that will try to validate it so
then the first thing basically what
we'll do is so we will install great
expectation
and uh then
um
yeah i'm i'm using uh databricks which
have also some free tiers so that's my
personal account so um uh it's also what
we use in my company
uh it's pretty cool pretty interesting
tool but it
also proposed like a host
notebook so i think it's interesting um
to show it in this so then we'll set up
on uh databricks and
for this
so
for second time i will not dive in like
the internals but if you want to look
into how i set it up in databricks then
you can just uh copy the notebook it
will be in the link of the presentation
that i will share after
and then finally we can uh
what we get basically we get a data set
we get some great expectation and then
we can load our first data set or why or
sorry our wine data set the red wine
and
we basically were
looked at the quality
and
one of the of the dimension basically so
what we'll do
uh we set up the
sorry we
we set up the great expectation and then
we can do the fun part which is building
some expectations so the first thing
that we would like to check for example
is that
the quality actually
in the
in documentation they say it should be a
value between 0 and 10 so
let's do that
and check what we have
and indeed
the test succeed and we should have
value between zero i can say that i had
this specific values and i even get some
cons so all good
then the second thing that we will do
another expectation is about the
sulfates distribution and we'll make
sure that the surface distribution stays
the same uh in our data set
and so for that what i can do is apply a
callback library divergence test which
basically means if the histogram of
is different some have some kind of
difference then the test will fail
basically
um so basically we get
we can run it and at the end like also
we get
some output we say what are the
different bins and what are the value
for them but
not very user friendly but
what you can do is then you say okay i
saved my suit of expectation
and
now i can
generate some kind of data documentation
like all the like tests that i've just
created now i will uh
i will render it is in the data dock
and basically then you get some kind of
documentation which says okay
i have two tests the first one the
quality it should be in this round and
take one of these value and the sulfates
should have
this
distribution more or less
are good so far
yes
which distribution do i use to compare
in the histogram no i didn't compare
anything here i just i
i took the the red
wine data set
and i
looked at the distribution of the raid
one data set and say the next and that's
my test basically i expect any new data
set that i put into this to have the
similar
distribution
no that was not test we here we were i
mean
exactly because we it's it right now we
were just saying it was not a test by so
sorry the question was like uh they did
about the test there was not a real test
in the sense i would say
look at the data
then
build a histogram on it and then do a
test to verify that the histogram like
the data the same data is have the same
distribution
according to the histogram that was
built on the same data so the test will
always succeed in this sense so
that makes sense yeah thank you okay
great
uh yeah now we have our tests of course
we should have more than one but i think
two is enough to to show uh in this
example and basically now we can load
our white wine data set which is very
similar looks
look the same
and now what we can do basically is
run
or test
on the white wine data set the one that
we the test that we created on the red
one and to make sure that does it make
sense and indeed let's
check so
they're all at this pop-up but basically
here we see we have two uh two tests but
one of them failed so the quality
succeed and actually you get this kind
of report like that's all the value that
we indeed saw
but the sulphur's actually we get an
error and we get like okay this is what
it should have been
that's is what we expected and this is
what we saw
uh i think that gives you kind of a
great bootstrap
when you want to do any kind of uh
i mean first it will allow you that you
have a problem and then also you you can
see directly
what seems to be wrong like you don't
have to dive into the code
or
need to reload the data set in some
sense
and that's it
on the
sorry that's it for the further live
coding i will go back to the
presentation
um yes
so
so in the last part
in this presentation i want to talk
about uh how we reduce data unit tests
in our at get your guide but first i
think what is pretty interesting is to
share like some of the incident we that
we had in the past
that triggered these initiatives
so for example what happened is that
what we have a change in the data
structure that led some to some
duplicates in our recommendation system
um we also had some uh missing feature
that we
in our daily production data set for our
for our prediction to to predict
and also we already happened that uh
once that we have a we use the wrong
column for correct
like this is the kind of thing that's
hopefully this data index is able to
should be able to catch
and so basically this uh
this incident led to action to avoid
reproducing such
to
such such incidents and what we did
basically is for example so we introduce
great expectations to
validate our recommendation data set and
we use that before we push them to our
customers so that if there is anything
wrong then we'll have the basically a
data set that is not up to date like
from the day before but at least it's
not something that is completely wrong
with wrong scholars score columns or
something like that
we also have
build in-house some kind of event
validator which is running regularly and
checking for specific values that we
have
and also we
most recently introduced some kind of
health check as part of our continuous
integration pipeline and basically also
we do some kind of uh we
will
open source some library to do some kind
of
sampling so basically that you can run
this health check that helps to
basically also run this health check as
part of the ci so you take your
production data you sample it
run it through through your health check
and if the results are okay in uh in
some
with
the expectation that you have then
you you can deploy basically or like any
new version then get all this uh
feedback loop of getting some production
data doing some kind of uh
some things like to to to to make sure
it's sampled to the right side that it
makes sense to it can run in few minutes
and then
make sure that's with a new version of
the code we do not break any vital
expectation that we have
at the at the end
and yeah that's it and so to conclude
um
so i think what i want to what i wanted
to share in this presentation is that
the importance of the data test uh in
our data products so i think it's
commonly accepted that you should test
your code
in our profession
but i don't think there is a lot
discussed about testing the data
but it is as important or even more
important because you don't really
control when the data is changing
um
so it's a new domain and there are new
and it's i think you need more awareness
around it and yeah as i've seen in my
company there is no civil will it i wish
we could say we're out we'll just use
great expectation for everything and it
will solve all our problems all use case
it's not really the case so it worked um
but yeah that's we are trying multiple
approaches and there is no clear winner
for us at least in this point in time
and but yeah pretty excited to see the
things going so with that's that's the
end of my presentation i'm really
looking forward for your
question remarks or also share any
experience that you have with your tests
or your data and how you test and yeah
data incident that you can have
thank
you thank you very much theodore for the
talk uh i don't know if there are any
questions
stuff from here
thank you for the talk um my question is
about some of the issues you have feels
like they could have been solved also
some kind of data versioning which is
also something
let's say for example if there is some
data that disappears you could
see it there is dvc which is popular for
that how do you think these two can be
used in conjunction or
is uh for example uh some of the
features you presented actually also
being handled by by some data versioning
or
what do you have to say with with this
uh i think that's
slightly two different uh problems i
think like exactly this data versioning
is is also good to have but
you can version bad data without you
noticing it right i mean if you decide
if you if you do some code mistake and
you take the wrong chromes or scoring
you can you can always
you can version it but you will still be
wrong and you will not notice it until
some of your consumer will tell you
it's completely wrong like why do we
have such recommendations and then with
this version and i agree with you you'll
say well okay it was wrong since this
point in time which is i think it's for
business it's important to know like to
have the like the scale of the incident
thing like that uh
so
but as you say i i as i say you will not
get the the alerting by yourself
basically that's i think the main
difference
thank you
thank you very much for the um for the
presentation i wanted to know more about
specific unit testing when you use
filters for example let's say that you
have different you have an attribute and
you know that the ranges will differ
depending on that attribute how does
how does the documentation
of in the great expectations framework
how does the documentation reflect that
do you need to does it identify whenever
you slice from the original data or do
you need to actually input that yourself
i think then here you are starting to go
into this specific use case like i don't
know if you have like if you want to
have something like let's say
you have some kind of companies and the
values that you expect for each market
uh
german vs uk vs friends
should have kind of different averages
then what great expectation has is this
concept of
data
for i forgot the name but basically you
can have a data set and like a subset of
this data set then you can apply a
specific set of
uh of tests like you have a certain
suite of tests a collection of tests
that you apply but for another subset
you can apply another
type of test and for the overall data
set with everything then you can apply
another one so they have this concept
but you will have to basically specify
the value for each of your
different data sets
thanks for the talk just a couple of
questions
i'm here
yeah i'm sorry
the first one is the report you
generated out of running great
expectation suite right would it be
possible to export that as a pdf or a
file or something you know just for us
to know what what past and what failed
in a production system and when we're
not doing it interactively and the next
one is comparing one data set to another
right so
like you showed the distribution
comparison would it also be possible to
say you know like i have you know
xyz values in one data set i also want
to have the same xyz in my second data
set would it be possible to do stuff
like that
really good questions um so the first
one is yes actually what's the
there are some technical
uh difficulties around using databricks
but basically what you have at the end
the outputs is just html and so
basically it's a static file static
it's just a static website and you you
can get like the list of expectations
and you can know which one was failed
you cannot see all the suites of
expectations uh i
if you want to the more i really
encourage you to go into this uh great
expectation website there then you can
just have the website running on your
machine basically and you will you will
see
uh the second one is comparing two data
sets yes it's a very common use case in
ml so basically you have like the one of
yesterday the one of today and you would
like to compare if they are good you
don't really care about like specific
values uh
so we are exploring that we
it's not native from great expectations
so basically what we have to do is to
wrap some code around with say okay we
take this data set we create some
expectations around it or like some
specific thing or you you you basically
take a
a set of data set from the different
days then you can compute some kind of
uh
95 percentile confidence interval for
this average of this value and that's
the one that will use to compute for the
next one basically to see like to kind
of some kind of detection so
you can build that we around the apr of
great expectation but it's not native so
you have to
do it yourself
yeah yeah thank you for the talk uh
yeah oh yeah okay
so um i think a question that emerges
with testing in general but i find it a
bit difficult to answer well here
is uh when do you do enough testing
right i think for unit testing in code
you usually you look at test coverage or
metrics like this
what do you suggest somebody would do
for because i find this hard to answer
for for data unit tests when do you do
enough testing and how much coverage do
you have of your question essentially
yeah
good question too
usually you don't have enough that's my
answer
from and basically what yeah uh
i mean
i think what you have to then like have
to look is what are the business impact
like maybe you have a feature but
and the feature can go completely wrong
but
if it's not the most top four more
important feature for your model maybe
it doesn't need uh
to be tested as well as the
important feature oh actually what what
you care the most actually is
the uh the output like what you also
have to customer i think there was a
some great presentation uh about like
if you if you want to do some kind of
monitoring of uh of a product or data
product general you you should test what
you get an input but also what you what
you will give outputs but if you have to
start somewhere and you always have to
start with one of them you should start
with the output so i will say first make
sure that what you give to your customer
is right because and they and and then
maybe tackle
what you do in uh what are the data
input
that will be and see that make sure that
you you know because if if there is some
data input that is wrong but your output
is still okay
is it okay
i think there was one okay sorry
he was
here from the start so
thank you for the talk uh i'm curious
that because you mentioned that you can
very validate your recommendation but is
that based on like you need to come into
the office every day and very fairly
manual or do you have like some tool and
can make automation
uh yeah so yeah so basically it's a task
so basically you you always say like you
you have this uh
uh assistance that take take the the
this data set apply this validation and
give the output and then you can
schedule it and so what we use in our
company is airflow but you can use any
kind of scheduler to basically what we
do is like we compute right we create a
data set
we do the prediction
and then we do the validation and if
it's successful then we put uh the the
the prediction into another bucket where
we know that now the that's whether our
customer will use it and it's done
automatically so it's like pipeline do
you mean yeah it's a pipeline it's a dag
basically yeah
how do you handle streaming data
obviously if you have data coming in one
at a time you can't take an average or a
distribution or a median or anything
do you batch it up and test it at the
end of the day or what
so we don't have that many uh bad use
case but we we are discussing it so that
it's it's coming basically but for me
the
when you have any batch data basically
you can always let's say batch it and do
some expectation on the batch
and usually if you i mean let's say you
have a batch every five minutes
uh what will happen like you can really
try to have a really smart process to do
it already on the stream and you will
know exactly when it's happened but if
you know it five minutes
after it won't change much in some sense
and i think it's much easier because
then you have the whole framework for
all your things you have something that
that's that you need to validate
thanks very much for the part of the
presentation i was just wondering have
you ever seen a case where your
production data has actually changed
through time and your old expectations
are now wrong
and how have you had to do that or how
do you notice and monitor that
yes so before they are doing data unit
tests what happens is
people change the data
then all things sometimes failed that's
a that's a good part sometimes they
didn't fail they just give rubbish and
then at some sometime in the future
people just come to us and say why do
you have
this
ranking all these recommendations and
that's that's terrible that's what we
want to avoid and now what we do
basically when we change hopefully the
data unit test will be the one that
first will fail and so we don't push in
production this new
these new things that where we know we i
mean we don't know what we are really
pushing right
and uh then we can basically look back
into the code look back into the data
and make sure that is this occur correct
or not or do we need to change our data
expectation or should we change the code
basically so that's the overall process
but then basically you are in control
that's that's a big like that's a big
part i think there are a lot of
things i i think it feels bad when one
of your customers come back to you why
do you have that answer i have no idea i
have to look it up right it's much
better if you are proactive and you say
i think we have a problem because of x y
and z
i think it's a much better stakeholder
communication in general
all right i think this is the last
question because we're running out of
time
hi there
i just wondered how you deal with more
fuzzy uh failures the sort of thing i'm
thinking of is
if
a test you're applying finds like
one percent of the values are invalid
then you might want to just ignore those
and throw them away and continue
versus if 50 were wrong then
you probably should stop so any patterns
or kind of toolkit support for that kind
of thing but actually that's exactly the
thing of like the i think where the data
unit tests are useful like maybe for
example let's say you you want to
compute some kind of ctr and then you
have to look at the impression and the
clicks and you have to kind of merge
them with some events and you
expect that some events will not be sent
or like you will not be able to
to match all of them but you expect to
match most of them right and you can you
cannot have a threshold you say i expect
to have at least 95 of the
of the of the events match
but
i
i know that's because system is complex
and not all events have standard i still
expect this but then you can have a test
to say if i have
more than five percent of missing events
that's where i should have a trigger
because that means that there's
something wrong have been introduced to
the system so that's that's basically
where the you can remove the fuzziness
into putting into something this is the
point where i want to be alerted about
this this problem that i'm aware of but
i i expect to be small if it's bigger
than that that's
big enough problem that i should look
into this
all right thank you very much theodore
yeah
thank you